[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody
so we're talking about solving systems
of differential equations x dot equals
ax where X is a vector of states that
kind of uh co-evolve in time they're
they're coupled and they're linked in
their evolution and time uh are linked
to each other and in the last few
lectures I've talked about saddle points
and unstable and stable points that have
you know real eigenvalues now we're
going to talk about what happens when
you have a System Dynamics an a matrix
that has complex or imaginary
eigenvalues and from the last few
lectures
hopefully you know you at least have a
kind of gut feeling that when I have X
when I have a complex eigenvalues I'm
probably going to be getting things like
cosines and Sines as my Solutions
because e to an imaginary number X will
give me you know cosine X plus I sine of
x that's what we learns formula so
that's what I'm going to do today let's
jump in I'm going to write this actually
out much more explicitly the system
we're still solving is
let's say DDT
of let's say that this Vector X has two
components Little X and little y kind of
the X and Y component of a
two-dimensional system and we're saying
that that equals
um this 0 2 minus two zero times X and Y
and this is my a matrix here
and it's pretty easy to compute the
eigenvalues of the system so we would
literally take the determinant
of a minus Lambda times the identity and
Lambda times the identity is just going
to be you know minus Lambda minus Lambda
here
so
um
this is literally determinant of minus
Lambda 2 minus 2 minus Lambda and that
equals
Lambda squared
minus minus 4 is plus 4 and that has to
equal zero for these to be eigenvalues
and so that means Lambda squared
equals minus four
which means that Lambda equals plus or
minus 2 I okay so this is this is the
kind of Crux of this lecture is what do
we do when we have complex numbers for
these eigenvalues so we know that the
solution of this um this system is e to
the Matrix a times time times my initial
conditions and I can solve that I can
break that down by using my eigenvectors
and eigenvalues but what happens when
this eigenvalue Matrix D has complex
numbers has imaginary numbers in it you
know I know that this is a real value
differential equation x is real X naught
is real DX DT is real a is real how do I
get how do I deal with the system that
has complex numbers in it how do I get a
solution that's real out with these
complex eigenvalues so that's what I'm
going to walk you through today
um and I want to point out it's pretty
easy to get systems that look like this
from physics so I just want to convince
you that this is in fact a very physical
problem
so if I take something like a pendulum
or a spring Mass remember my spring Mass
system was another good example
so either a pendulum for small angles
or I have my
um
my mass on a spring both of these
systems are governed by f equals m a
which is a second order differential
equation and I have something like X
double dot equals minus X
technically here if I had my angle
Theta my Dynamics are like Theta double
dot equals minus
sine of theta but for small angles it
looks like Theta double dot equals minus
Theta okay so so morally these are kind
of the same systems uh this one
oscillates for small angles this one
oscillates again cosines and Sines and
so I can create this larger system by
introducing you know x dot equals V and
V Dot equals minus X and now I have the
state of my system of X and v d DT of
that equals a matrix
times x and V and that Matrix again is
going to be 0 1 minus 1 0. so just
trying to convince you physically that
yes it is actually pretty easy to get a
matrix that has this kind of uh off
diagonal equal and opposite structure
that's exactly what I get from this Mass
spring system and for a small angle
pendulum here I made them you know twos
instead of ones just to make it a little
more interesting to show you what
happens when these are you know 2i and
not just one eye but morally this is
exactly the same system as this one down
here okay so we're going to solve this
we're actually going to compute we just
computed the eigenvalues of this Matrix
next we're going to compute the
eigenvectors and the inverse eigenvector
Matrix so that's definitely coming up
before I do that I want to give you a
very very brief review of some facts
from complex analysis complex number
theory that are going to help you
because we're going to be dealing with
these imaginary numbers and complex
numbers so I'm just going to spend you
know four or five minutes showing you
some really basic complex number theory
if you feel really comfortable just skip
this and go to the next kind of chapter
marker where we solve this problem okay
okay so complex numbers we're dealing
with
um you know these kind of uh sometimes
we call it the complex plane and in the
complex plane typically we have
um you know kind of a real part
and an imaginary part
um
and so we would write a number you know
X
plus I Y is a complex number with a real
part and an imaginary part and that
would be you know my let's say my
eigenvalue Lambda is going to have a is
going to be a complex number so
in other lectures maybe at the end of
this lecture I'm actually going to show
you what happens when this thing is not
just purely imaginary but it has a real
and an imaginary part so that's why I'm
showing you a generic kind of General
complex number here
and so we can so that Lambda in the
complex plane Lambda equals X Plus i y
is going to have a real part this is X
and an imaginary part this is why
and it's also very convenient sometimes
to write this instead of Cartesian
coordinates to write this in what are
called kind of complex polar coordinates
in terms of the radius of this this
Lambda the length from the origin
and its angle Theta in this kind of
complex plane
okay so this is a very common way of
writing this and you would say so Lambda
equals X Plus i y
and we could write down that x equals R
cosine Theta
R cosine Theta y equals R sine
Theta okay
good so the real axis the imaginary axis
radius and Theta or X and Y if you like
that's fine
and so you can do things like you can
say you know in this coordinate system
Lambda sometimes I would just say it's
you know R comma Theta in polar
coordinates
and you would say that this is R times e
to the I Theta
the reason we can do that is because of
Euler's formula and I had a whole
lecture on deriving Euler's formula from
the Taylor series it says that e to the
I Theta equals cosine Theta
plus I
sine of theta we derive this from
scratch this is true and so if I write r
e to the I Theta that is literally R cos
theta plus I times R sine Theta and that
is like my definition of x
plus I
y so I'm just convincing you that I can
take X Plus i y my complex number and I
can write it as r e to the I Theta this
is you know kind of X Plus i y is the
Cartesian coordinate representation r e
to the I Theta is the polar coordinate
representation using Euler's formula and
because again we're going to be taking
things like e to the Lambda T and so we
need to know what e to the i t is going
to be it's going to be cosine t plus I
sine of T very very important if this is
a seeming unfamiliar go back to the the
lecture on deriving Euler's formula from
the Taylor series I'll put a link
somewhere either in the description or
you know you can click on it from here
that much all I want to show you I mean
I guess you know Lambda squared is r
squared
um e to the
2i Theta or I2 Theta Lambda to the N is
R to the n e to the i n Theta and so on
and so forth
um
good so that's just my like little
primer on complex numbers because we're
going to use a lot of this e to the I
theta equals cos theta plus I sine Theta
and I want you to be comfortable
thinking of these complex numbers either
in their polar coordinates or in their
Cartesian coordinates
so now I'm going to get back to solving
this I'm going to erase this and solve
this
okay so uh we just showed that the
eigenvalues of this a matrix are plus or
minus 2i I erased all of that just put
it up here so now our kind of diagonal
matrix of eigenvalues is 2i and minus 2i
on the diagonal
and now we want to actually solve this
thing so we need to figure out you know
what are our eigenvectors T and then
what are T inverse and then we're going
to build this formula and actually write
down the solution this is a little
it's not terrible but it's just some you
know kind of irritating
algebra so bear with me this might be
the point where you speed me up to 1.5
times and I go chipmunk
um I've had a lot of coffee so that
might happen already so I'm just going
to show you again how to compute these
eigenvectors
and it's a good exercise and just like
these eigenvalues are complex conjugates
so if I have a 2i I have a minus 2i my
eigenvectors are also going to be
complex conjugates that's something
we're going to see so we're basically
going to find the eigenvector C1 for
um
Lambda 1 equals 2i and remember that the
way that we do that is we
compute a minus Lambda times the
identity Matrix and Lambda is 2i 2
imaginary I times the identity Matrix
and then we find what vectors C are in
the null space of that Matrix what
Matrix what vectors C get mapped to Zero
by this Matrix
so this Matrix is literally a minus this
identity Matrix times 2i
so minus 2i 2 minus 2
minus 2i this is a minus 2ii and we are
trying to find C vectors in the null
space of this Matrix okay so literally
I'm going to take this this Matrix minus
2i minus 2
2 minus 2i
times I'm just it doesn't matter what I
call my dummy Vector the elements of C
let's just say you know let's call this
like a and b
and that is going to we're trying to
find a and b so that that's equal to
zero okay
um and so I do that I actually write
down the system of equations and I get
that you know minus 2i
minus 2i
minus 2 I A plus two b equals zero and
similarly I have minus 2A minus 2 i b
equals zero and so from the first
equation I'm just going to move the 2ia
over and I this equation I guess I'm
going to move this one over and divide
both sides by 2 and I'm going to solve
for A and B okay to make this work
and what I'm going to find you can do
this out pencil and paper I'm just going
to write down the answer if a equals 1
and if B equals I that is a solution to
this so if I plug in uh 1 for a that's
minus 2i and I for B that's plus 2i that
of course equals 0. if I plug in 1 for a
I get minus 2 and if I plug in I for B I
get minus minus 2 is plus 2. so minus 2
plus 2 is also 0. so this is an
eigenvector
so c 1 equals
1 I is an eigenvector good so we found
one eigenvector
and now we want to do the same thing for
Lambda 1 equals minus 2i
and I'm like 90 sure this is going to be
1 minus I I'm guessing that's what's
going to happen because they're going to
be complex conjugates of each other I'm
just like my intuition is that the only
way that all of these complex numbers
can cancel out and give me something
real in this expression here because we
know that our pendulum oscillation gives
me a real Theta and Theta Dot and my
spring Mass has a real position so the
solution of this better be a real number
the only way that's going to happen is
if these are you know my eigenvectors
are complex conjugates of each other so
you'll be seeing that in a minute but
let's actually derive it
and I'll just change colors here for
sanity uh let's say that now my C2
C2 for Lambda 2 equals minus 2i same
exact thing we're going to take a minus
Lambda and minus minus 2i is Plus
2i identity Matrix equals
2i 2 minus 2
2i and similarly we're trying to find
the vector in this null space so I'm
just going to write 2i 2 minus 2 2 I
times some Vector a b
is going to equal 0 0
and again I'm just going to buy
inspection you can verify that if a
equals 1 and b equals minus I
so I plug in a equals 1 and then b
equals minus I and I put it in here I
get 2i minus 2i
if a is 1 and B is minus I plug it in
here I get minus 2
and then a
minus minus
2 so minus 2 plus 2 is 0. so both of
these are zero so this is also fine as
C2 equals 1 minus I
good so now we have our T Matrix here
T equals uh
one I
n one minus I these are the eigenvectors
of my system
now in my
uh you know I might derive T inverse
from scratch it's a real mess and I'm
not going to do it you can do this on
pencil and paper or you can do this in
python or Matlab just in of T it's it's
easy I'm just going to write it out the
inverse of T equals
um
it's one half of what I'm about to write
and I think it is 1 1 minus I I
all of this times one half I should have
put my one-half out there but I forgot
so I have d t and t inverse and now we
can build the solution
of this system using this expression
here so T times e to the DT times T
inverse and the reason I'm going through
all of this gory detail is specifically
because I want you to see I wouldn't be
doing all this boring kind of Matrix
algebra if there wasn't a point the
point is that all of these matrices with
complex numbers when I multiply them in
this very specific way all of the
complex numbers are going to cancel out
and I'm going to get something real
valued because if you think about it you
know time is a real number X naught is a
real number all of a is a are all real
numbers so I can't have a system that
integrates that moves forward in time
and is not real everything here is going
to be real even though the building
blocks of eigenvectors and eigenvalues
are complex okay so I'm actually going
to show you and go through the motions
here I'm actually multiplying this out
[Music]
um
so let's do this
um X of t
equals
and it's going to be at T times e to the
diagonal matrix T times T inverse so I'm
going to pull out this one half so I
don't have to keep dealing with it
times T which is 1 I 1 minus I times e
to the diagonal matrix T that's e to the
2 i t 0 0 e to the minus 2 i t
Good Times T inverse
1 minus I I one
and I'm trying to think if there is a
good way for me to avoid I'm not going
to break these into their cosines and
signs until the very end I think so I'm
just going to start multiplying this
stuff through
this equals one half
one I one minus I
times
e to the two i t
either the i2t
uh
e to the minus
I 2T this is going to be minus I
e to the i 2 T and this is going to be I
e to the minus oh my God
I to T all of this you know times x
naught
times x naught and so now I'm going to
multiply it
these matrices together so this equals
one half
and now I multiply all of these matrices
together and it's going to be a mess I'm
going to have like all of these terms
here so I'm actually going to maybe
color code each of the four terms so you
can tell them apart so this is going to
be e to the I 2T
plus e to the minus I 2T that's the
first term
the next term is going to be
i e to the
i2t
minus i e to the I 2T that's this one
then I'm going to get this one here is
going to be
minus i e to the I to T
Plus
i e to the minus I to T and then the
last one is going to be now this is the
worst because I got eyes times I's I
squared is negative so negative negative
is positive
e to the I 2T
plus so now this one's also I times I
times negative is Plus
e to the minus I 2T that wasn't so
terrible okay so this is like literally
The Matrix times
X naught and I'm going to look at my
notes and make sure I didn't botch
anything up before I go to the next step
so uh that looks good I times
minus that plus that that looks good I
times that
this should be a minus here
because that was times that yep good and
then e to the I to i t plus e to the
minus yes this looks good
okay excellent
um
and
now we can start to simplify all of
these terms and this is where it gets
pretty interesting here is
um again I'm just going to write out
that my
um
e to the I 2T
equals cos
2T plus I sine
2T so I see I have I to e to the i2t's
and I also have e to the minus i 2ts e
to the minus I 2T
is cosine of minus 2T cosine's an even
function so that's just cos
2T
and sine is an odd function so sine of
minus 2T is minus I sine of positive 2T
okay so these are the building blocks
for all of these Expressions here so
maybe I'll just go color coded pink here
so
um e to the i 2 t plus e to the minus I
2T is literally this plus this so the
signs cancel
so that equals uh
2 cosine
good that was easy
blue here is going to be you know I
times
e to the I to T minus
e to the minus I 2T
now if I take e to the i2t
minus E to the minus I 2T the cosines
cancel and I get 2i sine of 2T
so this equals 2
and the I's cancel so minus 2
sine of 2T
minus 2 sine of 2T good
um
then I'm going to do this one here which
is uh this one is I times
minus E to the I 2T
Plus
e to the minus I 2T
okay so that's literally
this one minus this one so this one
minus this one the cosine still cancel
and I get minus 2i sine 2T
so this is minus
2i and there's an eye out here so it's I
squared sine
2T
and I squared is negative and negative
those cancel and that just equals
positive 2 sine
2T and then the last one I need to do is
this orange one
which is again exactly the same as the
pink one so I'll just say you know this
one is also equal to 2
cos 2T this is literally the exact same
expression as this one and so it has two
cosine T and so now I can write down the
actual solution this equals
all of these have a factor of two and I
have a one-half out here so I'm just
going to cancel that and I'm going to
write down that this is a
cosine 2T
this is a minus sign
2T
this is a cosine
2T and this is a
sign
2T all of that
times my X naught let's call it X naught
and uh whatever y naught okay
evolution of this problem so that was a
lot of math and this is the solution X
of T equals this and notice everything
is real valued cosines and Sines that's
really nice it all worked out at all
canceled out because of this combination
here because my eigenvectors were
complex conjugates of each other this
all folded up and all of the imaginary
Parts canceled out and I only got Sines
and cosines out which is what we expect
when we had um you know e to the Lambda
T's with complex lambdas earlier our we
had to basically take the right
combination of them so that we only got
real numbers out I'll point out you know
this is not only real valued
um
this is a real valued
real valued
and this is what is known as a pure
rotation Matrix a pure rotation
Matrix so you'll see this come up a lot
in math this is a matrix that rotates
this vector by an angle 2T so this will
literally rotate this Vector if this was
in The X Y plane and had an angle
multiplying by this we'll rotate it by
an angle of 2 Theta this is an uh like
an R sorry not two Theta 2T so this will
rotate the angle of this vector by 2T
and so it'll keep you know rotating
around in that way
okay um that was a lot so I think what
I'm going to do is I'm going to tidy up
my board get rid of all of this get rid
of all of this write down my solution
and then we're going to draw the face
portrait so stay put
okay that was a lot of erasing and some
of my pens had started to dry
so this is the solution of this
differential equation
that had complex eigenvalues plus or
minus 2i and I already showed you that
this corresponds to a system
um
basically this is the Matrix form of a
system uh you know X double dot equals
um
minus 4 x so this would be like a mass
on a spring with a spring constant of
four okay like a really stiff spring
that's you know causing this thing to
oscillate at this frequency so there's a
physical intuition about this and as we
expect if I have something that we think
oscillates the solution should be
written in terms of Sines and cosines
and so um the way that we're going to do
this now is we're actually going to
write this draw this phase portrait so
again in
I don't know why I called this X and Y I
really should have called this X and V
because then that would have been more
physical position and velocity so just
think of this as a velocity
so X and Y but really this is X and
velocity
um at least in this spring Mass system
or in a pendulum system
and so essentially what this means this
pure rotation Matrix and you can plot
this in python or Matlab like literally
compute this Matrix and multiply a
vector by this Matrix and watch it
rotate it around if I have
some initial Point let's say I start in
the you know one zero Direction and I
multiply this through it's going to
rotate that vector and it's going to
rotate it around in a circle so that
whenever T goes from zero to Pi this
will make a full Revolution and if it
goes you know from 0 to 2 pi it'll make
two revolutions to 3 Pi it'll make three
revolutions so as time goes on this is
basically just continuously going around
in this circle and a bigger initial
condition goes around in a bigger Circle
and I can't draw circles apparently but
this is supposed to be a bunch of
concentric
circles this is the phase portrait of
that dynamical system any initial
condition I start at is just going to go
around in a circle
and what that means physically that's
actually very physical if I think about
this you know let's say that this is a
velocity and we're talking about our
Mass on a spring
uh what this means is that
if I if I pull this thing to some big
initial X to some big initial condition
and I let it go with zero velocity so my
y-axis is zero so I let it go what's
going to happen is it's going to start
moving
towards the x equals zero position it's
going to move towards the x equals zero
position and gain velocity
and it's going to pass through the x
equals zero position at maximum velocity
then it's going to overshoot until it
eventually comes to a stop V 0 velocity
then X is going to reverse and come back
around and again have maximum velocities
that passes through x equals zero and
then keep going forever and this thing
will oscillate with no friction forever
and that's what these circles are these
circles are different initial uh initial
conditions you know if the smallest
circle is me pulling it only a little
bit and having a small oscillation the
bigger circles are me pulling it a lot
and having a big oscillation but this is
essentially what we get is periodic
rotations in this phase plane in this x
position velocity plane this thing is
just rotating around and around and
around and that's a very intuitive
physical solution of this differential
equation okay and we wouldn't have been
able to do that without these complex
conjugate eigenvalues
these are the only lambdas where e to
the Lambda T is going to pop out Sines
and cosines okay which we know that this
system has
Center fixed points so this is called a
center because it's kind of like a
bullseye a center fixed point
and this is stable but sometimes it's
called neutrally stable so it's kind of
it is stable
I'll write this down it is stable
but it's sometimes it's called
marginally
or neutrally
neutrally stable which means that kind
of if I like breathed on the system
wrong if I perturb the system a little
bit and gave these eigenvalues a little
bit of a positive real part or a
negative real part it's going to
collapse the stability and make it
either you know asymptotically stable or
asymptotically unstable
good this is an important example it's
it's difficult that was some of the most
math we've done in this series you know
there's a few Boards of heavy algebra
but it came to this very intuitive
simple solution and that's what I really
wanted to show you
okay last thing I want to show you now
is
um
specifically what happens if I breathe
on these eigenvalues if I perturb the
system a little bit let's say I add a
teeny bit of friction here so now I have
a little bit of a damper on the system a
little bit of a damper maybe a minus you
know d x dot here
um oftentimes what that's going to do is
that's going to add a little bit of a
negative real part to this eigenvalue
okay and so I'll show you an example
it's not exactly like this but it's very
close to this where now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to add a little bit
of an off diagonal I'm going to say that
this is minus 1 minus 1.
those eigenvalues are now going to be
you know minus 1 minus Lambda 2 minus 2
minus 1 minus Lambda the determinant of
that is Lambda squared
plus 2 Lambda
minus minus 4 is
um
still Plus 4.
equals zero and I'm hoping I didn't
botch this up but my solution should be
minus
2 plus or minus the square root of 4
minus 16.
I don't feel like I'm doing this right
um
Lambda squared
plus Lambda plus Lambda it's plus two
Lambda
minus minus 4 is that and so the
solution should be minus two plus or
minus
um
B squared minus 4AC is minus 16
divided by two this is not working
um so this is minus one plus or minus I
feel like I've totally messed this up
this should be
um
I know that the answer is plus or minus
2i I'm not exactly sure what happened
here
um
just check my math please compute the
eigenvalues of this system and confirm
that it's minus one plus or minus 2i it
should be I'm just going to say like
let's assume that these eigenvalues are
plus or minus 2i
um if they're not it might be minus one
plus or minus some number I it doesn't
really matter
um what matters is that Lambda has a
negative real part and a imaginary part
that's in a complex conjugate pair and
so I don't think that my eigenvectors
are going to change I don't think that
anything is going to change the only
thing that's going to change now
is that my Solutions e to the Lambda T
are now going to have this real part
this e to the minus t
times e to the I 2T
and so this is e to the minus t
cos 2T plus I sine
2T okay and in all of that Matrix math I
did before where I had all of that those
matrices multiplied all of them is going
to are going to have this e to the minus
t pulled out front so this whole
solution here is going to be exactly the
same except now it's going to be
multiplied by e to the minus t out front
and what that means physically
is that instead of just having pure
oscillations now I'm going to have
oscillations
with a decaying exponential envelope so
now my oscillations are going to be
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
as time goes to Infinity so I'm still
going to have my system oscillating I'm
still I pull my spring back and I let it
go it's still going to oscillate with
Sines and cosines but now the amplitude
of that oscillation is going to get
smaller and smaller and smaller with an
e to the minus t envelope
and so the way that we draw that phase
portrait is very similar
perfect concentric circles now if I
start with some initial Condition it's
still going to oscillate and go around
with this rotation in time but the
radius is going to get smaller and
smaller and smaller and so it's going to
approach
the origin like that
and again that is also very physical if
I pull my spring mass and I let it go it
is going to oscillate but the amplitude
is going to get smaller and smaller and
smaller as it goes to the origin
if I did the opposite and I made these
plus ones then my eigenvalue would be
plus one plus or minus 2i and now my
oscillations would grow with an
exponentially growing envelope and I
would change the direction and this
would be blowing out to Infinity
so this is what's called a stable
spiral
or a spiral sink a spiral sink
and of course if I had changed the
direction and made this plus one that
would be an unstable spiral or an
unstable Source or a spiral source so I
just want to get you feeling very
comfortable that you can work with these
eigenvalues you can draw these phase
portraits and you can intuitively
understand
what these dynamics mean if I have a an
eigenvalue Lambda that is a plus or
minus IB this is going to give me
oscillations
this is going to give me something that
oscillates and this is going to give me
you know exponential growth
or decay
based on if a is positive or negative if
a is positive the system will be
exponentially growing and oscillating if
a is negative I will be exponentially
decaying and oscillating so very very
important very very powerful these are
the building blocks of all of dynamical
systems and in the next lecture I'm
going to show you now what happens if I
have
a non-linear system X naught equals f of
x maybe this has quadratic and cubic and
other terms that are not linear but how
we can find fixed points where f of x
equals zero and linearize them to
approximate the system like this and
then these are going to be the building
blocks even for non-linear systems so
that's all coming up thank you
[Music]